welcome everyone it's so nice to see
everybody here in New York City up at
Columbia University on this beautiful
day for the 14th annual David and
Dinkins leadership in public policy
forum
it's just my pleasure to introduce the
Dean of the Columbia University School
of International and public affairs who
will open up the conference for us this
morning Dean John cotesworth Thank you
Thank You Esther and welcome again to
all of you to the 14th annual David and
Dinkins leadership and public policy
forum this year the nickens forum will
focus on what may be the most serious of
all the problems confronting the United
States as we struggle to recover from
the worst economic setback since the
Great Depression of the 1930s the crisis
in state governments and state budgets
let me begin by recognizing our
distinguished guests beginning with the
star tennis player of the CEPA faculty
former mayor david end
Mayor Dinkins presence on our faculty
inspires all of us to do better to serve
the public interest no matter who we are
or where we live and to do so with
compassion humility and grace which are
the enduring harm hallmarks of great
leadership let me also acknowledge the
presence here today of u.s. senator
Kirsten Gillibrand I believe this is a
senator gillibrand first public address
to an audience at Columbia University
since her landslide election triumph
last fall and I believe we will be
joined this afternoon I don't see him
here now by former governor david
paterson one of Colombia's most
distinguished alumni as you know the
purpose of the Dinkins forum is to bring
together educators government officials
and community leaders to discuss the
challenges facing our cities our own New
York as well as cities throughout our
region the nation and the world today's
lineup of innovative thinkers and
practitioners does great credit to the
terrific sefa sepa faculty and staff who
have brought us together so I want to
thank all of you who have taken time out
from your impossibly busy schedules to
share your ideas with us today and to
say a special word of thanks not only to
mayor Dinkins but also to professors
ester Fuchs and Dorian Warren who did
such a great job as they do every year
using this event
and at Carol banks mayor Dinkins
intrepid and into that debacle assistant
and program going
finally let me just make three
historical observations to start us off
first the current recession as you know
is often compared to the Great
Depression of the 1930s however that
Great Depression hit the United States
in 1929 and it was not until 1933 when
unemployment hit twenty four point nine
percent of the workforce that the new
Roosevelt administration took office and
it was not until 1934 when federal
government spending began to have an
impact on job creation this suggests at
the least that rapid passage of
president obama's stimulus package early
in 2009 played a key role in averting a
repetition of the Great Depression it
also points to how important learning
the lessons of the past can be for
effective public policy second as you
know the unemployment rate during the
remainder of the 1930s never fell below
fourteen percent historians have debated
why it took World War two to lift the US
economy back to full employment two
factors stand out one was the reluctance
of the President himself and especially
the Congress to raise the deficit and
debt levels high enough to have an
ignition airy in the economy
Keynesianism was in the air but not in
the federal budget a second reason iment
States so high and here is my third and
final point if you can follow the
complicated math a second reason why
unemployment stayed so high was the
extreme conservativism of local and
state governments which cut spending and
raised taxes in order to balance their
budgets for much of the 1930s local and
state budget surpluses more than offset
the modest expansionary effects of
federal deficits FDR himself set off a
major recession within the depression in
1937 when he encouraged Congress to cut
back spending in order to balance the 19
38 federal budget so what does our own
history tell us about the role and
significance of state budget crises
during periods of economics distress
perhaps more than our current debates
over fiscal and debt policy yet
recognized while it is true that local
and state governments account for a much
smaller proportion of overall government
government spending now than in the
1930s it is still true as in that
long-ago era that what happens at the
state level one state at a time can
still have a major impact on whether and
how fast this country emerges from
today's great recession many thanks to
you all for your presence here today for
another great David and Dickens forum
you know I often say to audiences that
here in in New York I'm frequently in
the presence of African diplomats
because the United Nations is here and
they have a custom instead of
identifying by name a lot of
distinguished people they'll simply say
usual protocols observed and so skip
heartening you will understand why I
don't call your name and Roscoe brown
fighter pilot and all my other friends
out there you you will forgive me if I
don't call you by name but usual
protocols observed that means you've
been you've been acknowledged I Thank
You Dean cotesworth and thank all of you
for joining us here today for the 14th
annual David Dinkins leadership in
public policy forum we're all anxious to
hear from our keynote speaker and
senator Kirsten Gillibrand and to
exchange ideas with our excellent panels
so I will be more brief than I would
otherwise be before going further I must
thank Dean cotesworth for hosting our
gathering again this year and for his
leadership of what is arguably the most
complex school in our university at his
urging and under his leadership sepa has
redouble its efforts to marry public
policy with global concern in ways that
other institutions have not succeeded in
doing always with the aim of grooming
global leaders and aiming them with a
arming them with a practical as well as
theoretical grounding the world the
nation and the Academy are experiencing
in especially volatile period and we at
sea / and at Columbia University look
forward to the continued stewardship of
John Coates worse as Healy lends his
considerable knowledge expertise and
support to our programs including this
forum I must also ask that we pause to
remember a colleague
who he lost on April first three days
before the publication of his
groundbreaking work on Malcolm X as Dean
cotesworth wrote in his announcement to
the CEPA community the afternoon of his
passing professor Manning Marable
devoted his life to the struggle for
racial equality and social justice and
was a towering intellect and a man of
immense personal courage we mourn the
loss of this friend in scholar and we
will miss him as you know the topic of
this our 14th forum centers on the
challenges facing the nation state
governments as they struggle to recover
from the worst economic crisis since the
Great Depression and we have assembled
quite an outstanding group to help us
address the issues we're fortunate
indeed to have with us today for
individuals who have occupied key
decision-making positions in the state
of New York and the city of New York and
who are intimate with the profound
fiscal issues that we are now
confronting please join me in welcoming
the 55th governor of the state of New
York David Patterson who if David is not
yet here he will be former new york
state budget director dr. Dow Forsyth
former new york city budget director and
Finance Commissioner Mark Shaw and
former new york city controller bill
thompson
I thank you gentlemen for taking the
time to share your experience views and
analysis with us today in our first
panel on the new york state fiscal
crisis balancing city and state
interests and those of you who remain
with us for the second panel will hear
from two of the most knowledgeable and
passionate representatives of the
nation's unions the executive director
of New York City's largest public
employee union District Council 37 of
the American Federation of State County
and Municipal Employees Lillian Roberts
and the president of the 1.5 million
member American Federation of Teachers
Randi Weingarten we will also hear the
perspectives on their panel topic
distributing the cost of economic
recovery government business and labor
offered by the president of the Brooklyn
Chamber of Commerce Carl hum and our own
professor in Huffington Post columnist
dr. Steve Cohen who is executive
director of the university's Earth
Institute
our panelists will shortly be properly
and thoroughly introduced by today's
panel chairs dr. ester Fuchs professor
of public affairs in political science
and dr. Dorian Warren assistant
professor of political science I think
then both for conceptualising the topic
of this forum and refining upon the key
issues so that we can focus our
discussion and we are most grateful to
them for urging the participation of
such a distinguished distinguished group
of panelists dr. Fuchs one of Cephas
most prolific scholars and practitioners
gave life to this forum 16 years ago as
founding director of the center for
urban research and policy and she has
consistently played a major role in
bringing the most compelling public
policy issues to the floor for an airing
Esther is no stranger to the inner
workings of city government having
served as mayor bloomberg special
advisor for government and strategic
planning through his first term in
office and if her resume reads as if
it's taken from who's who in urban
policy that's because it is sepa
students are fortunate to receive the
benefit of her knowledge and her
experience as director of our urban
policy concentration dr. Warren as many
of you faculty and students know is a
scholar of the study of inequality in
American politics and the politics of
Labor race and ethnicity and community
organizing and focuses on the politics
of marginalized groups one of the
youngest and most popular members of the
faculties of sepa and the political
science department Dorian is a fellow at
the institute for social and economic
research and policy a faculty affiliate
at the Institute for Research in
african-american studies and a fellow at
the Roosevelt Institute in his spare
time he coordinates the seminar
series for the center for urban research
and policy and serves on our law schools
center for social institutional change
and it's low-wage work project with
professor mark berenberg Dorian has been
much in demand by the media as an
analyst of the controversy surrounding
wall marks efforts to open stores in
large cities and its implication for
labor and is writing a book on the
subject following each panels
presentation we would be interested in
some discussion of the problem with
those of you who have been observers in
participants in efforts to address the
issues and we are especially interested
in hearing the thoughts opinions and
questions from those students in the
audience that doesn't mean the rest of
you can't ask questions but we're
particularly interested in the students
because we recognize that they are our
future this would be a good time for me
to acknowledge the student volunteers
who have worked hard so very hard to
make this year's forum possible and I
ask that they raise their hands so those
who are still in the room many are
downstairs or upstairs I'd like to them
to raise their hands so we might
acknowledge them and show our
appreciation
and i know you will understand my desire
to acknowledge the Magnificent work done
by my staff of one carol banks she has
worked so hard and successfully at
bringing about this form and you have to
understand that's not all she does and I
am constantly interrupting her flow and
her work to ask her to do something when
she's got this form in mind so I know
you will all understand when I say
please join me in acknowledging
gratitude for her hard work
and now I have what I was about to
present our keynote speaker but on one
occasion so many years ago I acknowledge
everybody in the room by name and my
bride was standing next to me and I
failed to acknowledge her presence we
will have been married 58 years come
August and I just want you to know that
the mother of our grandchildren and the
mother of our children and grandmother
of our grandchildren is with me our
wonderful wonderful choice thank you
darling for coming
now I have the honor of presenting our
keynote speaker to set the tone for our
discussion as the leaders of our state
governments and our cities continue to
press forward and contending with the
crippling damage to their economies that
was the legacy of the Bush years and the
further assaults threatened by the 112
Congress they are running out of options
faced with the end of the federal
stimulus package and scrambling for
sources of revenue our state's find
themselves between a rock and a hard
place more and more states are declaring
their inability to make headway against
the persistent fiscal problems their
cities and regions face while the
actions proposed by others Wisconsin
them among them have been at very best
very sobering the brinksmanship of the
threat of a government shutdown over the
past few days is what the latest example
of the crisis atmosphere that have
seized the country as our jobs our
health our children's education are held
hostage by a struggle for political
power and special interests we've heard
threats of cutting federal aid to the
states and refusing to bail out States
in danger of defaulting on their bonds
of encouraging trouble States to declare
bankruptcy and of eliminating collective
bargaining rights of public employee
unions Congress urges passing the budget
pain on to the state's States on to the
cities and the cities to taxpaying
public into the midst of the storm has
stepped a young lawyer and mother of two
from upstate New York a Democrat twice
elected to Congress from a predominantly
Republican district in recognition of
our increasingly important role as a
member of the New York State
congressional delegation she was
appointed by Governor Paterson in
January 2009 to fill the vacancy created
by Hillary Clinton selection and
Secretary of State and became the
youngest senator in the 111th Congress
winning the Democratic primary last
September with seventy-six percent of
the vote she went on to retain her
Senate seat in the November special
election since he's been in the Senate
she's been instrumental in the
nomination of fellow New Yorker Sonia
Sotomayor to the United States Supreme
Court and the repeal of Don't Ask Don't
Tell and in passage of the sadocha sir
Drogo 911 health and Compensation Act
she is co-sponsored an amnesty bill for
undocumented immigrants endorse
legislation to legalize same-sex
marriage in addition that junior senator
has made significant contributions to
efforts to negotiate a path through the
budgetary crisis we're here to discuss
today she's been a strong supporter of
the Obama administration's recovery
planned and budget measures an advocate
of relief for homeowners facing
foreclosure and a campaigner for
adoption of a more equitable Medicare
reimbursement formula to provide
budgetary relief for big states like our
new york she is co-sponsored the
employee free choice act that would
permit employees to form unions by
filing a majority authorization and as
opposed to No Child Left Behind Act
because of the burden it places on
already strapped local budgets we are
honored that she has come to speak with
us today and I am very very pleased that
she in addition to agreeing to come
today she's promised to play tennis with
me I hear she's pretty good so I ask you
to join me in welcoming the junior
senator from New York State Kirsten
Gillibrand
well it's such an honor and privilege to
be with you all here today I want to
thank Mayor Dinkins for giving me this
honor and privilege to come and speak to
such an esteemed audience and so many
young minds I also want to recognize
Joyce for her service and unbelievable
dedication to our great city mayor you
are someone who has taken on more
challenges and some of the toughest
problems our city and our state has ever
faced from freighting crying to judge
drug abuse to improving New York's
criminal justice system to providing
better access to health care for our
families and fighting to give every
child in New York the opportunity he or
she deserves to succeed you've been a
champion for the voice of the voiceless
you are an extraordinary leader and I
want to thank you to be my friends I
want to recognize professor ester Fuchs
for her leadership and dedication John
cotesworth as the dean for his
leadership Michelle moody Adams Dean of
Columbia College for welcoming me thank
you all for your leadership and enormous
dedication to service it makes a huge
difference I'd like to spend a moment on
our great governor who's just arrived
Governor Paterson
I want to thank you governor for your
extraordinary strength in leadership
governor patterson was the first
governor in the entire United States to
really sound the alarm bells of what
this fiscal crisis would actually look
at I can tell you he was the first one
to come to Washington to work with
federal leaders to demand solutions he's
someone who brought parties together to
work on tough crisis that our state was
about to face so I just want to thank
him for not only seeing the store before
it arrived but for finding solutions in
advance he's someone who has dedicated
life for service and for others and I
just want to thank you for that
dedication governor well it is a real
privilege to get to address all of you
and I'm particularly excited to talk to
the students you are our future you are
the decision-makers and policy makers of
the generation to come and I really want
to engage you today in the importance of
public service because we are going to
hear from the final finest panelists
this afternoon about how to solve these
budget crises that were in and we're
going to hear about problems solutions
tactics strategies and really the
choices that are made but I very much
want to know how you are feeling and
what you are doing because you are the
solutions of the future and i would like
to engage you on your pathway toward
service and i want to talk a little bit
about how I got here as a way to start
that conversation the reason why I got
involved in public life was because I
had a role model very early on in my
career I had a role model in my
grandmother Polly Noonan who was just a
young woman who never went to college
she didn't have many much much of means
but she was a she worked she was a
secretary in our state legislature and
for some reason she wanted to have a say
in public life she wanted to be part of
the debates of the day she wanted to
impress upon her priorities on those who
were the elected leaders and the way she
got involved is exactly the way hazel
Dukes would tell you to get involved
she's sitting right here in the second
row that you have to organize you have
to be heard you have to make sure that
the people around you under
stand what your concerns are and so she
engaged a whole generation of women to
care about politics and so she with all
these other women would work on
campaigns they do door-to-door they do
envelope stuffing they do phone banking
and so I had the great privilege of
being a young woman growing up in a town
where my grandmother worked on a
campaign every fall and she would bring
me and my sister and brother and my
cousins with her to care about these
issues my first political memory was
sitting in a long table of women all
stuffing envelopes all talking about
things they cared about and being part
of the political fabric that creates our
democracy and so that role model was
very very important to me so it taught
me a couple of life lessons early it
taught me the life lesson that women's
voices matter that what you do with your
time matters and that activism makes a
difference and so I've tried to apply
that in my whole life as one of my
earliest lessons so when I came to New
York City as a young lawyer having went
to Dartmouth undergrad and you see day
law school I found myself at a big law
firm pushing papers working on big cases
and wondering what am I actually doing
and I saw a speech by First Lady Hillary
Clinton and I don't know if any of you
remember if you've ever seen it is her
1995 speech that she gave in China the
first worldwide women's conference where
she challenged the world to say women's
rights are human rights and human rights
are women's rights and to give that
speech at that moment at that venue to
the Chinese people where they were still
killing girl babies in the countryside
she gave a call to action that we have
to care about women's rights and we have
to care about who they are what they
stand for and what needed to be
addressed in their lives so that is
something that drove me into politics I
thought you know I'd need to be doing
more I need to be part of these debates
and so I got involved in politics on a
local level I got involved in local
campaigns around New York I got involved
on the national level I joined a women's
group to engage other women to care
about politics and so being a young
lawyer thinking about I need to do more
and just working a big law firm I really
felt I needed to leave the law and do
something else and I couldn't find my
way I tried all certain ways and just
didn't find that way
but I come to an event similar to this
event and the speaker at this event was
andrew Cuomo are now governor and he was
giving a speech about why activism
matters a why being a Democrat mattered
why helping people mattered and I
thought oh I agree with absolutely
everything he's saying but I've been
having trouble leaving the law I tried
to work at the US Attorney's Office to
no success i tried to work it a bunch of
charities to no success i tried to get a
paid position on Hillary Clinton's
campaign to no success and I couldn't
find my way and so I go up to macho as I
say I say secretary Cuomo I agreed with
everything he just said but it's an
insider's game how do I get involved how
do I have a say how can I make a
difference and he challenged me at that
moment he said well would you come to
Washington now I was young lawyer I was
up for a partner in about a three months
I had a nice house in the suburbs I had
a mortgage and I thought really am I
going to go to Washington not to end the
conversation early I said of course and
sure enough I got the interview and I
went down to Washington and I
interviewed and he gives me the job on
the spot and so I had a long hard talk
with my family that night and at the end
of the day I said this is what I've
always wanted to do I don't need a big
law firm I don't need to stay in New
York I can go to DC I can make a
difference and I accepted the job and so
off I go to Washington and I only got
the chance of working for secretary
Cuomo for about seven months because it
was the two thousand election and we
lost that election so there were no more
appointed positions but after that
experience I decided and I hope every
single one of you in this room does
public service at some point in your
career because when you have the ability
to help people where you have the
pinnacle of policy and politics and
advocacy all meeting at one place you
can really make a difference and I
thought this is what I am built for this
is what I have to do in my life and so
now having no appointed position since
the democrats lost the election i
thought i might actually have to run for
office so I thought long and hard and I
decided to move home and decide to raise
my family in upstate New York and soon
enough I decided to take a chance and
take a real chance on running for
elective office now this seat was a
tough seat though it was a two to one
Republican seat so it was a
red seat it was the most Republican seat
in the whole state and even a very
esteemed colleague who teaches a class
here at Columbia my pollster Jeffrey
Pollock said it can't be done so I say
to Jeffrey and hopefully some of you are
in his class I say to Jeffrey I said
Jeffrey you know I'm thinking about
running for Congress in this
congressional district what do you think
and he says Kirsten you have no chance I
said no chance he said no chance I said
well what happens if i run the perfect
campaign clearly i could win then he
said no you can't win there are not
enough Democrats to vote for you I said
well you know what happens if I raise a
lot of money what happens if i raise two
million dollars in run a great media
campaign he said Kirsten there's 21
Republicans there's not enough Democrats
to vote for you and being very
frustrated I said well what happens if
this guy gets indicted can't I win then
and Jeffrey being the consummate
politician says well it depends what he
gets indicted for so that was the lay of
the land of my congressional district
but I said well worst case scenario i
elevate the level of the debate we talk
about the issues I challenges incumbent
on issues that I know he's wrong about
and then I at least take my shot in
serving full-time we run the race we run
the best race we could and students from
Columbia came up to my district and
knocked on doors we had people from all
over the district all over New York
knocking on doors in the greatest
grassroots effort I think we've seen in
a congressional race in our state we
were literally making 10,000 phone calls
every night we were knocking on 20,000
doors every weekend that had never been
done in my district before but it was a
real test case in democracy what does it
take to elect somebody who care about
what does it take to elect somebody that
shares your values what it takes is you
it takes your passion your dedication
your willingness to say I want this
person to represent me that is what our
democracy is all about and miracle of
all miracles we win the election we win
by 63 wit was fifty-two fifty-three
percent in that first election
fifty-three percent a six-way margin
even the New York Times called me a
dragon slayer so
that was our first victory and after
that you know they thought oh she's
vulnerable never happened again they put
up a self underspend seven million
dollars in negative ads but we showed
him we won that election by a sixty-two
percent margin and then our great
governor our great governor gives me the
chance of a lifetime to serve this whole
state to actually serve all of our
constituents as the u.s. senator and
that's been an amazing journey for me
and it we were lucky enough to be
elected statewide with a sixty-three
percent victory last November so thank
you governor for that opportunity but
none of this gets done on our own and so
much of what history teaches us is that
those who come before us pave the way
their sacrifices their accomplishments
are what lead us to where we are and the
battles that we fight at any given
moment and one woman in particular who
was very inspiring and very important to
this state in our country was Geraldine
Ferraro and we have just lost her
recently many of you were part of that
celebration of her life at her memorial
service but she was a pioneer she was
somebody who paved the way for women
everywhere to run for office to seek
office and I loved her convention speech
in in 1984 because she said the issue is
not what America can do for women it's
what women can do for America and that
is an issue in a struggle we are
literally still fighting today we still
only have seventeen percent women in
Congress that is very little number of
representatives who are women fighting
for the issues we all care about and
having women in public life makes a
difference women will look at problems
differently they will solve them
differently they will attack them
differently and so we need to have all
of our best and brightest serving to
make sure that we can face these
challenges so today's debate is going to
be about one of those challenges how do
we wrestle with the fact that we have a
budget crisis on the state level a
budget crisis on the federal level
programs are being cut across the board
but what these budgets are about is they
are moral documents these budgets are
about choices that we make and what are
our core
our values who do we fight for what do
we care about what issues are most
important and what we've seen out of
these last few budgets particularly on
the federal level out of this Republican
Congress our choices that are not the
right choices for our future cutting
education cutting Pell grants try to
cutting early childhood education
cutting women's health care you know I
understand there may be a debate about
reproductive freedom and this work in
this country but how can you cut
spending for pap smears for mammograms
for women and infants nutrition for
prenatal care those are the safety nets
that we need for all our families in our
communities so we have to make those
choices in these budget debates we have
to make the choices between cutting
corporate tax loopholes or making sure
that we have job training in this
country these are real choices these are
choices that make a difference as to
whether we have a growing economy moving
forward so I am very optimistic that
with the leaders we have here in front
of us we have our new york city
controller right here we have randy
weingarten right here we have a hazel
dukes we have leaders here that are
going to make the difference on these
debates and I just want to thank you so
much for coming today and giving me a
chance to speak to you
thank you so much senator for making the
time to come and for being part of our
forum we can thank you enough i know
that the student fear were inspired by
your words and i have to think that even
some of us older folks continue to be
inspired by those words it was really
quite extraordinary thank you